MATCHING IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
THIS KIND OF HARMONY, THIS
SYNCHRONICITY DOESN'T JUST
HAPPEN.
YES, THERE'S A DEEP EMOTIONAL
CONNECTION.
YES, THERE'S A NONVERBAL
COMMUNICATION.
YES, A NEAR TELEPATHIC BOND.
BUT THERE IS ALSO MORE.
A TEXT MESSAGE THAT ARRIVED SOME
TIME AROUND 5:13 A.M.
THIS ONE SAYS NAVY AND BEIGE.
NOT TO BE CONFUSED BY SAND AND
NAVY OR VERY NAVY.
MY MORNING MARCHING ORDERS.
DRESS ACCORDINGLY.
THERE IS ASTOUNDING SPECIFICITY.
GREEN.
GREEN SKIRT.
MORE GREEN.
KELLY GREEN, JADE GREEN.
JUST JADE.
EMERALD, AND MINTY GREEN.
I THINK WE'RE CLEAR HERE.
IT'S ALSO A HUMAN SARTORIAL
FRUIT BOWL.
TOMATO, WATERMELON, ORANGE,
RASPBERRY, DEEP RASPBERRY.
MULBERRY, PUMPKIN AND, FINISH IT
OFF WITH PEACH SHERBET OR MAYBE
SOME WINE OR BLUSH.
AND ON THE SUBJECT OF BLUSH,
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO WITH
THIS?
THIS DISEMBODIED ANATOMY GUIDE
BOOK.
THIS PG-13 HIDE THE KIDS AND
GRAB A LAWYER EVIDENCE TRAIL?
MY TEXT FEED IS LIKE A ONE-WAY
TICKET TO HUMAN RESOURCES.
BUT ALSO, AN EDUCATION IN WHICH
YOU LEAVE NOTHING TO CHANCE AND
LITTLE TO THE IMAGINATION.
SHOULDER, WRIST, UNKNOWN BODY
PART.
MY WAIST.
WHO ELSE'S WAIST COULD IT BE?
ONLY YOU WOULD BE SO CLEAR, SO
GIVING, SO HELPFUL AND
UNDERSTANDING.
AND THAT'S WHY IN THE END, IT'S
GOOD THIS IS NOT A MONTAGE OF MY
BODY PARTS.
NO ONE NEEDS TO SEE MY ANKLES OR
NECK OR ELBOWS.
BUT ALSO, TO BE HONEST THIS
MORNING, MY HEART, WHICH IS JUST
A LITTLE BIT BROKEN.
EVEN IF YOU ARE MOVING JUST A
FEW HOURS AWAY, I WILL MISS YOU.
ALL OF YOU.
ALL YOUR BRIGHT HUES, ALL YOUR
SHADES OF AWESOME.
FROM MAGENTA TO MAGENTA UNTIL
RED DO US PART.
SO, YES, WHILE TODAY I'M NOT
JUST BLUE BUT VERY BLUE, COLOR
ME LUCKY.
VERY LUCKY.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO SIT BESIDE
YOU, TO BASK IN YOUR RAINBOW.
>> JOHN, OH, MY GO